hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play right fear okay you left off
I just passed by some bed guys so that
fatties bed boogeyman anyone whatever
you want to call oh it's a real ladies
wolfy Sophie the hell are you doing here
well hi Simon
hello what I don't I don't understand
anything now you don't need to
understand you don't understand what do
you think the whole [ __ ] city is
crawling with monsters it I just I mean
suddenly you just turn up on these
rooftops yeah make sense to me what are
you doing here
are you hurt monsters Simon you're
scaring me
scaring what the [ __ ] this is just sick
she's a monster well he's a monster
don't look up man let's talk about
something else
Oh
I don't know you've been no just
confused not too bad thank you
I keep getting paranoid yeah I'm glad
you're here too so feet still don't
trust it I've been alone all this time
you're gonna be true I see some stuff
but what about yourself why are you here
are you hiding up here from those things
no I really don't understand what you're
talking about
mm-hmm I'm just thinking same thing
about murdering me yeah I've been doing
a lot of that too do you remember how
you got here I don't know
because I woke up myself but it wasn't
an alley and wait I can probably show
you no assignment if we just sit here
for a while don't trust you yeah yeah do
it man oh sure don't do it man okay
nothing Bad's brawling a nap not
brightest freaking Ellie do you want to
know something yes yes yes I do yes I do
I want to know just what in the [ __ ] is
going on here is it about that doctor
guy in the gas mask Simon please no I
mean about school yeah what
well I don't know if he knew but I
always had a hard time at school you
there well you were pretty much the only
guy who was kind to me out of it I never
said it but I really want to thank you
for making my life a little bit more
bearable you're a cute guy Simon oh yeah
yeah yeah you did have it pretty rough
thank you she was yeah even if she is a
monster
I guess I helped you because I liked you
you were one of the prettiest girls at
school and I don't know I just I guess I
wanted to protect you if you know what I
mean I don't love you but I think I
could if we got to know each other
better okay back off man just going on
strong Sophie why haven't you said
anything
I never had the courage I mean I wasn't
exactly the toughest kid in school it
has killed 10,000 months now we're here
lowlife
I've always liked you Sophia Oh Simon I
don't know what to say I always liked it
too but not in that way
I always thought that you were just a
friend nothing more I'm sorry
friend-zoned our door
[Music]
but [ __ ] damn so much stuff has happened
lately all this craziness the darkness
and and the ball Susan I think I'm going
crazy
I'm so glad I found you know this is it
I know a lot of things
Frankie friggin you guys yeah really
was it you who tried to phone me by the
way yeah I wanted to talk to you to get
away from it all
Oh but what out here
no away from everything away from all
this what what do you mean you know full
well what I mean I don't know what you
mean wait a sec you you mean old oh ah
come on
what do ya know
[Music]
Sophie
hi Nietzsche what wait why the foot this
this isn't making any sense
oh guy there's the thing you might want
to look up you can have to it
yeah was it why why you sick [ __ ]
I will kill you dead carcass not what up
oh gosh shoot you down I don't know
oh yeah ready for some hard reload buddy
what
how is that win that put that was it was
that this bro heads at me I've thrown
heads at me Oh shucks hi oh that's not
how do I get away from those
don't move
regular boys no wait
yeah that's for Sophie I'm pretty sure
that someone is messing with this guy I
mean why else would number one her his
like secret crush calls her things up to
a roof and then she denies him hardcore
totally friends owning him and then she
kills herself Oh
what I'm doing where I'm going
I like how Simon is toughening up and
not scared of the monsters was it you
murder you okay no I can't go back this
Turner Garnett and I don't want to fall
off and die because I know I haven't
saved in a while and it's devastated I
would be
get back up here they're a mess of it
sound away
my theory is that this guy got that car
she is in a coma
that was done on purpose and somebody I
kidnapped him and his starting
experiments on totally totally let go Oh
duh
up video saying there we save over the
you will dies
I gotta cut it here thank you guys so
much for watching it as always I will
see you in the next one
markiplier Oh